I don't just give you the answers for
these I want you to think about the way
they were okay I've sort of scaffold
this is the real question nanometers he
remembers how many meters are yeah we'll
get to that in a second it's 10 to the
most life but the important thing is
well how do I think about this okay now
I think we could all do this part partay
I think we could actually all do it in
our heads because it's sort of easy
enough what is the answer how many
senators it's 490 right so i'm going to
write this off now the important thing
is like you guys are so good at
converting meet incentives because you
deal with them or as a matter of course
right these are units weren't familiar
with their the units it's kind of to
scale interview I can't help you
something about it now here's what I'm
going to do to try and help you
understand the technique that will help
you convert so you can do the next one
which is not as obvious um how many
centimeters are there in a meter there's
100 right now because in a second like
one hundreds got a pair of zeroes right
so that's that's easy to do it but this
is going to have a heck of a lot more
zeros so a hundred I'd rather avoid just
like i did before i'm going to use index
notation to help me what's 100 index
notation it's 10 how many survivors
there are two zeroes right so yes 10 12
so what I'm doing is I've changed this
one meter one meter I've changed it into
10 squared centimeters does that make
sense and of course you can punch that
into your Catherine up and that gives
you the number you guys already talked
okay now the reason this is useful is
because I can apply this approach with
nanometers and it works better than just
like oh I think I know what is our oh
yeah
he tells us to do next with what we good
question pay attention he's not a matter
Venus I'm interested in how many know
them is there are in our media right now
centimeters I really small that's why
there are lots of them there sandy with
nanometers except even more now some
people probably already looked up how
many nanometers are there in 1 meter 10
to the 10 to the power 9 i'm remembering
right okay so you might remember when
you get to those like I'm first off
those preferences like mega kilo mega
Giga Tara etc okay it goes in like lots
of 30 so this is three lots of three so
that's how many nanometers there are in
a meter so all that's left is to
actually write it out as an ordinary
number so 49 how many zeros so I have to
make the number nine times zero is
bigger but one of them is already taken
here right so that leaves one two three
four five six seven eight zeros left
over and that's because that I mean is I
really little okay okay so I was just
checking this for you um these prefixes
are not on the formula sheet which means
two things number one that we're going
to be as important number two if you are
needed to like leave your questions such
as this what standard procedure you can
go look in the HSC exams is they'll tell
you given that there are 10 to the 9 90
meters in a media don't give you the
question on the base event so you still
need to use it but they won't expect you
to remember
okay that's such a good question now
this is this is why I sort of
unhappiness right what she's talking
about why do they always go about he is
there is a milestone where does it
appear when did we did our table right
we said that one nanometer is a really
really tool number so that's why it's 10
to their minus 9 meters okay like a meat
is a big thing he's a midnight okay and
you can fit like when I have a look at
like how big is an animated on here and
the answer is it's this 20th or
literally microscopic fraction of a
meter yeah things I thank you okay so
therefore you see how I've gone from
this line it's at this line like I've
actually multiply both sides by 10 to
the power 9 if you multiply this by 10
to the power of 9 you're just going to
get one do you see how they sort of
balance each other out so that's where I
see this that's where that number comes
on because I'm converting to nanometers
not away from knowing me actually
I was right here's what I would do hey
welcome grab a seat we'll talk later I
would do one of these things I would
write one of these statements I got this
one or this one whichever your brain
goes through first okay what does each
one be this woman's anatomies are really
really small things in comparison to
bina and this is how much or the
conversation is how many nanometers that
are their enemy of EDSA a lot of them 10
to the 9 like a thousand million good
way cuz I'm excessive you got for us
yeah so if you have a sleeve it like one
of those you'll get the conversion right